hello look up the GameSpot plays we're
gonna play with some EXO zombies I'm
Tania Dwyer Rob handler hey do my
friends hey very well you can actually
call me Rob Zombie oh Christ so we're
gonna spend the next 15 minutes
singing dragula regular how many of
those lyrics do you remember man was it
with you Emma all of them and let's jump
right in I love how the exo-zombies
stuff is like literally right here on
the menu uh-huh
just start it's great we're punching
right in so here's the really awesome
cinematic Danny that I personally love
to watch and I watched it like three
times now because I think it's really
great it's got a bunch of Hollywood
actors in it and what's like the I think
was the first zombie stuff they did in a
black ops 1 rather they like brought in
you know couple Sarah Michelle Gellar
was in one Danny Trejo was in one mm-hmm
which famous individuals are in are in
this thing so you got Malkovich John
Malkovich you are being John Malkovich
Bill Paxton okay right and another one
is rose rose mcgowan okay and probably a
lesser known is John BIRT burthen all
who's who's John burthen all he is Shane
from Walking Dead and he was in wolf on
Wall Street okay so he's gonna have sex
with somebody's wife during the course
of this game we can hope so yes
hopefully so this is a taking place in
appleís is all right yeah it's a good
research facility so yeah so this one
has it as they kind of explain here a
pretty decent story or more sort of than
the other ones where they basically say
they they had a bunch of soldiers or
squads that got killed and they bring
them back to their facility and then
turns out they are infected right and
he's and now each of these characters
has their roles Bill Paxton is like the
executive John Malkovich's the janitor
in the beginning this is John birth
bruising walking
this whole show this is called shame
sure Shane is the head of security
Rosa gallons like some kind of like
butts research tech real bad real quick
yeah like this is the whole place is
blowing up yeah and all these zombies I
guess this is the big difference between
this and the previous zombie I played
with on Call of Duty that they are all
wearing EXO suits they are very mobile
yeah and [ __ ] Hey Atlas corporation
so dudes you get to choose who you are
and those are ok random its randomized
you go you gotta play online I'm gonna
play online it's it's just way more
entertaining
is it like left for dead where you're
starting a moon part of a map and you're
trying to get to the end there is an
objective based or what is this so yeah
you start at the very bottom there ok
near truck and you're exactly right so
there are basically you can see rooms
that you can unlock as with the other
zombies the idea is that you in this one
especially is you want to get to the
where the exosuit is which is very top
ok because that's how you move around so
you start off with that one oh wow
although I'm Shane I'm gonna have guns
apparently yes you just kept this way
with one little stupid pistol yeah
start slow but yeah you want to get to
the exosuit in order to move around and
get out of those you know tight
situations with zombies yes so to all
the zombies effects those on them they
all start off really really slow like
this but ever here and they throw it off
without exosuits
or they will have it on well as it
appears but they just won't be mobile
when you use them and stuff yeah so
around like I don't know I'd say around
oh man maybe like five eight or eight
will say you'll start seeing them jump
up onto a bus or something like that or
- forward like you can and that's when
they get really tricky so this stuff at
the start is this because you've been
playing this now you've proved you
played hours and hours of this right
yeah like is this you know first round
second rent or and stuff just like super
tedious to you now because you yeah I
mean it doesn't get good until you know
you get like yeah so and then it starts
cute and starts to pay starts thinking
I'll pick it up and everything but
here this is probably the most boring
stuff you just actually the main thing
that I actually say in these early
rounds is that you know get headshots to
get more points which in turn you know
will let you buy weapons all across the
campus weapons okay presumably nobody's
sharing points in this you were like
when you shoot zombie you're getting the
points for it
exactly okay so does that ever piss
people off yeah oh yeah you'll hear
people get like in the chat like through
that far in the beginning so here's a
new one is ordnance drops so here you go
whoa so he there's three things you get
camouflage which basically hide you from
zombies for a period of time because you
get a drone that follows you around and
then you get either the last one is a
remote turret okay and those happened
randomly I don't there's nothing much to
him but he didn't buy that or anything
he just like okay the other thing to
know you mentioned yeah you buy guns but
the other thing is you buy as the last
ones is the mystery box which will
appear as you turn on the power
genetically they now call the 3d printer
but it's just like a random gun okay and
try to get so what at certain stages
there are these three 3d printers and
you just kind of is the first come first
serve or yeah
they cost a thousand credits okay it's
good thing you've got ones that you
would have for 20 to spare you know what
I'm saying oh yeah looks good high but
so this one here's another thing is yet
what's different is you get kind of like
they they take they take apart the
exosuit and they kind of divide it so
here is the EXO slam rice which you
can't get until one the powers on and
until you get your EXO ability but this
is just one move you get where you
essentially slam down what so you can
use that in there because you've gone
through this stage I can't use it now
because I haven't gotten we're still
making our way to the server to the X
okay so these guys actually looks like
they open up a different door oh so
there are multiple ways through the
levels as well oh yeah and you typically
want to be like conservative of how you
get there cuz you kind of end up
there's basically my opinion like two
paths to the exosuit yeah but in this
case the person kind of like use
additional doors they shouldn't have so
you can open more zombies to come in and
get you then that and like you can just
blow money with you open to me door
right okay yeah so you're gonna need to
jump Malkovich tada
you've probably stopped with his life
already but I'm just won't quit does he
do have any zombies in here is that
because you guys are kind of like spread
out yeah I've run through a lot or
absolutely yeah so right now we're kind
of spread out so you know you everyone
gets their kind of set amount of zombies
so here you go so here's the exosuit oh
wow oh I'm ready and it's free
arrey arrey so this is huge now there
you go shake jump GameChanger dashes its
potential the only way this could
possibly go wrong is if for some reason
the zombies were able to do the same
thing yeah like that guys now here's not
something to know these electric cars
right here yeah you are near them
sometimes it'll explode - but if you're
near then and they hate you you it
powers down your EXO so you can't jump
right hey Claire they ground you how
long is that left for I'd say like I can
live no not that was like five seconds
cool but it sucks because they if things
get so crazy that you just need it you
need that stuff and it completely
eliminates your hug - so you don't even
know like um what type of wave it is or
anything like that so it's pretty so
it's not the wave up in the top left
that is way before now about hit five
okay so is it normal to the suit around
this level around 11.45 yeah absolutely
and I think it's been kind of easy up so
- yeah so like they're getting the suit
up to the getting the super part seems
to be like a like a real like slope a
what the [ __ ]
Resident Evil 1 all of a sudden oh this
is so this has always been so good is
there you know what there well I've seen
electric ones yeah oh yeah these uh
these pups are a real mean
this has always been the zombie thing is
like around you know every five 10
levels you get get your dog from your
dog yeah and they added a new type of
whoa down boy
yeah that'll be appropriately [ __ ]
either always like the easiest thing so
I they the only reason for this type of
wave my pain is to like there's at the
end of every dog wave you get max ammo
okay so it's always like that the guys
inference it's like a polished cleanser
or something here's my left here is the
3d gun I'll guess out hopefully I'll
have something worth is it is it anyway
based on like the way they're rotating
there or is it just all deriving my
worst things you want great perfect for
close quarters going home a combo oh so
crossbow is actually pretty cool I like
the car
fresco is basically the arrows are
basically can see oh wow
so would you dump your sniper there as
well oh yeah I got rid of it see you can
only have one at a time to weapons
attack to but like one little shitty one
or however you like okay just really
don't like this left oh nice you know
one shot with a scope link let me post
up and pick off this zombie got him it
doesn't work like that
though what's the highest level he guns
it alright was actually last time I
played which was nineteen oh I keep
hearing like 2025 is like pretty high so
he's also upgraded weapon Oh which
really just is damaged or anything else
and it changed your you know skin of the
upper weapon which is really cool so at
this stage you've gotten the exosuit
which is like your objective there is no
like exit here you're just fighting
waves until you basically overcome right
yeah exactly actually there's one more
thing to do and I kind of blew my points
on that 3d printer but the next thing
you do is you get perks so it's kind of
showing you which was the EXO slam
I'll show you the map there's
essentially one two three four
oh yeah yeah I say and it's actually
kind of interesting is which is
different from previous zombies if you
want to get them in a certain order
right so I found out is there's you know
it better uh or increase health what you
want to get first yeah and then you want
to get a sleight of hand which is faster
reload now the thing about these perks
though is that if I go down I lose the
last perk I've got right okay so you
want to get the last perk which is the
worklist one because then you can
essentially go back and get it again
course but you want to hold your health
one for as long as possible does it draw
for something is that what happens it
just disappears okay I need to go back
and buy it again then I come over here
let's Christ down I'm gonna get him oh
no which one is it Malkovich is it rose
mcgowan oh you just running away from
his buddy yeah what happens if you don't
get some one time is yeah he's out but I
got him I got you got your baby Rose is
back
it's over there's like dialogues between
all the yeah you'll hear him once in a
while and it's pretty great dialogue
Malkovich always makes me laugh this is
like the [ __ ] hate blinds all the
time it's so great I'd love if that was
his only line he kept saying it over and
over again well it's it's some form of
like how much he hates Atlas it's a
great [ __ ] Kevin Spacey that's paid
more than me to be in this so I found
this all go today is there a history
eggs Easter eggs in this game okay you
do these certain things you like stomp
on it on a thing in like one these rooms
and then you random stuff like I don't
know how people can discover the here so
you watch there's a lever you shoot okay
and it falls out right I don't know how
someone found this out and then you get
up here and you get X with slam and you
slam on this thing and a key and a
security card comes out if you get more
of these things that are just randomly
just doing stupid [ __ ] like that you get
this ending where a helicopter comes
it's like every will get to evac and
hell that becomes a negative and dies oh
and it keeps going yeah yeah let's keep
going it's like alright great
they put that in add some flavor too
because there's only one
level this is the one level current yeah
yeah so in the next expansion facts are
gonna start adding in other versions cuz
yeah oh it's 25
oh shoot burn alimony and that's sweet
sniper rifle man ow oh I'm gettin it
turret fire guns laughs whoa I'll see
assault wrong just call it anytime yeah
so when things get hairy I call this
thing in and falls me around it's
actually pretty
so here I'm trying to do these Easter
eggs okay that's pretty great so what
you do again this is just so random how
people figure this out it doesn't make
any sense to me uh where is it so
there's there's like three things that
to do okay where is it
okay here's one so little is that white
of the valkyries yes exactly so you
there's two other things you find there
like like surgeon tools I don't get it
okay and okay so just play like a couple
of bars of yeah and then you'll see and
then it kicks off okay let's find the
other one so there's this one okay do
you know the third is third one yes I do
so this this this place I just place
right of the vodka yeah right yeah it's
like both in Vietnam dude
I'll be honest I actually really love it
it gets me fired up and everyone else
can hear in his log oh really yeah nice
oh yeah absolutely use it throw it about
that yeah I think right Ibaka is good
shed good opportunity to use a drone wow
that sort of not taking any prisoners I
love the look of the donor run fair you
see oblivion come through yes yeah it
runs be exactly electrum it's not white
oh so these things are all spread across
the map - this is like the equivalent to
in other zombies where you put up boards
to slow them down
yes they they just took that out
completely which is kind of a bummer
Allen I like doing that and they just
have these terminals that randomly
generate oh they generate four credits
oh okay
Jimmie's oh alright level nine signs it
get cranked up a bit I'm really into
this crossbow actually yeah the cross is
good one minute I'll do this - I got
enough money out
oh it's cut down down for the count oh
that was great
Wow everyone got shanked real good yeah
but who cares who cares because what cuz
right of the Valkyries is playing pretty
good it's good
alright that is a Call of Duty advanced
warfare exo-zombies says that and what's
this available for you're playing on the
Xbox one currently it's exclusive for
Xbox one exclusive yeah so everyone else
will have to waste to get us but if you
want to play it right now it's on the
Xbox one Rob thank you very much Rob
coffee that's running pleasure as ever
and for more kpop plays of various video
games stay tuned to games.com we'll see
you next time
you